[Music]
welcome back so in the last lecture we
talked about the compressed sensing
problem and how under some circumstances
you can get away with measuring far
fewer measurements than your full system
so in let's say that X is an image which
is sparse in Fourier space you could get
away with measuring a massive
subsampling of the pixels in X so maybe
only 10 or 20% of the pixels in X and
you can infer what the sparse astir s
that satisfies this measurement equation
is and once you solve for that sparse
vector s the sparse vector of Fourier
coefficients you can inverse Fourier
transform and reconstruct your full
image so this sounds kind of like magic
it's not and I'm gonna walk you through
conditions on when this will and will
not be possible ok so just to remind you
this is kind of the picture we're
dealing with here we have some
measurement matrix C we have some
Universal and coding basis sigh I'm
gonna think of this as a Fourier or a
wavelet basis but it's a big n by n
matrix
hopefully orthogonal unitary that kind
of nice properties of sy and s is a
sparse vector that is basically our full
image Fourier transformed or wavelet
transformed ok
so we're trying to solve for s we know
sy everyone knows besides just the
Fourier basis we know C we know which
pixels were measuring and we know Y we
know the value of those pixels that we
measured and so what we're trying to do
is solve for s the sparse vector out of
all there's infinitely many vectors s
that satisfy this underdetermined system
we're trying to find the sparse assess
that satisfies this using an l1
optimization and I'll just write that up
again we're going to try to find the
minimum one norm s such that Y minus C
sy s is either equal to 0 or less than
some epsilon I'll just say less than
some really really small number because
that's more general okay so we're
basically trying to find an S that
almost approximates almost equals almost
satisfies this equation even if there's
a little bit of measurement noise that's
what this says and we're trying to find
out of all of those infinitely many S's
we're trying to find the one that is the
Spahr cyst which is going to be achieved
by this one norm regularization okay
that's what we're trying to do now I'm
going to walk you through what are the
conditions when you can expect this to
work and not work okay so the first
really really important condition is
something called incoherence so what we
need is si to be incoherent sometimes I
feel incoherence C needs to be
incoherent with respect to sigh okay
this is a really really important
condition I tell you exactly what this
means but basically what it means is
that I need the Rose of C to be kind of
orthogonal to the rows of side to the
columns of psi if my rows of C are
really really parallel to any columns of
sy then they're essentially only
measuring that column and they don't
give me information about the other
column so remember the trick not not the
trick the the big point here is that sy
as a universal basis that could encode
anything this s could be the Fourier
coefficients of a picture of a mountain
or a dog or a human face or a coffee cup
this is a very expressive library and if
my cup my rows of C are two parallel
with any columns of sy then essentially
those C's are only measuring those
columns of sy and we lose the full
generality of the library so C must be
incoherent with respect to psi which
means that kind of in words C cannot be
- oops
so in words what this means is that si
cannot be two parallel to any columns of
side to side
so si cannot be two parallel tips I okay
and I'm gonna give you some examples of
good measurement matrices and bad
measurement matrices to walk you through
this okay so these are all different
types of good measurement matrices that
you could use that would be incoherent
with respect to this basis sigh okay so
our example of random pixels or random
kind of point measurements here is a
good one
you could also generate this C from a
Gaussian normal distribution so like a
just a every pixel is randomly
distributed that's this one you could
have kind of a Bernoulli distributed
where you basically flip a coin on every
single entry of Si and it's a 0 or a 1
you can also have sparse or masks like a
kind of a sparse Bernoulli mask here and
the point is that all of these have some
randomness built into how you're
measuring okay and that's really really
important because if I don't have
randomness built into this measurement
matrix C then I'm probably going to be
measuring certain features in psy more
than others these random measurement
matrices are with high probability kind
of sampling the full column space of psy
so that this this vector Y has
information about s no matter which
columns S is exciting okay so these
measurement matrices have to excite all
of the columns of psy unless if you want
s to be you know any signal
reconstruction okay so that's really
important is that you need C to be
incoherent and generally this is
achieved through randomness now I will
point out that although mathematicians
love these Gaussian measurement matrices
because it's easy to prove theorems
these are not very practical in a lot of
engineering applications like I don't
know
if it's easier to take a megapixel image
and take Gaussian random linear
combinations of all of the pixels to
create all of the entries of Y that
actually might be harder
to generate this this Gaussian
measurement these single pixel
measurements are extremely engineering
relevant because in many situations a
single pixel means a single spatial
measurement so if I'm measuring the
ocean a single pixel is measuring at one
point in space and so I personally like
these sparser kind of single pixel
measurements even though there may be
not as mathematically as nice or as
robust as these these Gaussian
measurement matrices that's just kind of
an aside and I'll also point out that
single pixel measurements kind of Delta
functions in space are almost optimally
incoherent with respect to Fourier basis
remember that the Delta functions excite
all fourier frequencies and so these
little Delta function measurements are
actually really really good when you
pair them with discrete Fourier
transform or discrete cosine basis okay
so that's also really cool an example of
a terrible measurement matrix would be
if I literally just took columns of sigh
and transpose them this would be a
terrible measurement matrix you can see
I just picked columns of sigh and
transpose them and I'm gonna walk you
through why this is such a bad
measurement matrix so there should be an
equal sign here y equals C times bisaya
times s if I measure in this way C times
sy is only going to excite those columns
of sy that are parallel to these rows of
C and so this is literally the theta
matrix all of these matrix examples by
the way are actual data and actual
optimizations that I've run to find you
know these are actual actual matrices so
this C times this sy equals this theta
ok and you'll notice here that this
theta is not measuring any of these
frequencies here in s okay it is an
identity for these super high
frequencies it's not measuring any of
the low frequencies of s so the way I
think about this is that this C matrix
is measuring
this portion of the Fourier transform so
it's able to pick up this frequency here
but it's not able to get any information
about these frequencies here because
it's not exciting any of these columns
of psy okay so this is an exceptionally
bad measurement matrix because it is
very coherent with respect to psi okay I
hope that was somewhat coherent the
basic idea is that we want our rows of C
to be not parallel to any columns of
site we want them to be a linear
combination of all of the columns of psy
so that each of these measurements Y is
telling us information about all of the
potential entries of s okay good the
other piece of the puzzle here is how
many measurements we we need to take so
this vector S is called K sparse if it
has K nonzero entries okay so if this
thing has five nonzero entries it's five
sparse or K sparse with K equals five
and so I have to measure more than K to
find those K nonzero Fourier
coefficients and so my number of
measurements my number of measurements
and sometimes I call this P P is my
number of measurements it has to be
proportional or on the order of K log n
over K where K is how sparse my signal
is and is the original dimension of my
my full dimensional measurement you know
this might be a million if it's a
million pixel image okay and so what
this tells us is that the more sparse my
signal is if K is like two I can get
away with not that many measurements P
is gonna be on the order of two x log 1
million over two and you know log of a
million over two is like six it's not
bad okay
so this is small if K is small but as
kbecque gets bigger and bigger and
bigger maybe this is only 10,000 sparse
then this is actually a lot of pixels I
need to order I need to measure more
than 10,000 log and over 10,000 pixels
okay so
the scales kind of almost linearly in
the sparsity of X of s but there's this
log and over K and notice any time you
see an order here you should be asking
yourself there is a constant out here so
this actually equals some some constant
times K log n over K where this constant
k1 depends on how incoherent c is with
respect to psi so this is related to C
and sy and essentially to their inner
product how incoherent or how coherent
they are okay so better measurements C
allow me to take fewer of them okay
but as a back-of-the-envelope for the
best measurement you can think of let's
say Delta function single pixels for
Fourier this K is gonna be at least
around 3 or 4 something like that and so
for example if I had a megapixel image
let's say I had 1 megapixel image so N
equals 10 to the 6 and most images let's
say I have in a 10 to the 6th image I
need to keep like I don't know this is a
little dangerous to do live let's say I
need to keep 10 to the 4 sparse that's
and this is really low it should be a
little higher than that maybe closer to
10 to the 5 ok then I'm gonna need to
take at least some constant 10 to the 4
times log of n over 10 to the 4 that's
log of a hundred and you get to decide
if that's log base E or 10 I don't
really remember times this constant I
said was related to the incoherence but
it's usually about I don't know five
right so this is if it's log base 10 of
100 that's 2 times 5 times 10 to the 4
is about 10 to the 5 okay or 10 percent
of our original image so if I want to
keep if I want to keep 1 percent of the
original image I need to measure 10
percent of the pixels randomly ok this
is super back-of-the-envelope you
I need to measure a little more or a
little less maybe your signal is not
actually this sparse maybe it's more
like 5% in which case this would go up a
lot okay but that gives you just an idea
of how you would work this equation to
get the number of measurements that you
would need to take okay okay good so
that tells you kind of what types of
measurements you need to take how many
measurements you need to take I will
point out and this is really important
there was a big advance in applied math
15 years ago that allowed us in to solve
this system of equations for the sparse
assess it is now possible okay without a
brute force combinatorial search it's
it's now a convex optimization to solve
for this sparse assess if these two
conditions are satisfied okay and if
these are satisfied then you get
something called the restricted isometry
property the restricted isometry
property and what that means is that C
times sigh this big measurement matrix
acts like a unitary matrix like an
isometry matrix it acts like a unitary
matrix on sparse vectors on sparse
vectors s and remember that unitary
matrices will rotate pairs of vectors
but it'll preserve the angle between
them and kind of the distance between
them and that's exactly what we want
when we're doing this compressed sensing
problem is we want this C time sub site
to kind of preserve the geometry of
sparse vectors and if these two
conditions are satisfied then there are
rigorous mathematical results saying
that you have this restricted isometry
property which means at least for sparse
vectors for K sparse vectors s this
measurement matrix acts like an isometry
or a unitary matrix and so kind of the
gia geometrical information in in pairs
of vectors here is preserved in pairs of
vectors here and that's that at least
gives you a flavor for the mathematic
underpinning why you can do this
optimization but I will point out that
just because you can solve this system
of equations doesn't mean it's easy this
is extremely extremely expensive to
solve for this s given these
measurements why especially for a large
megapixel image I mean at least when I
used to do this this is kind of
supercomputer type computations and
there are better and better algorithms
coming online to solve this but this is
by no means cheap okay it's possible but
it's not it's not in expect it's not
it's not inexpensive so when would you
want to use this well there are some
applications where measuring the full
resolution X is really really expensive
and speeding that up or measuring less
of this might save lives
that's a great example of one you'd want
to use compressed sensing okay so for
example one of the classic examples of
when compressed sensing has been used is
for infant MRIs in in hospitals okay so
if you want to get an MRI of a really
really small baby they're moving around
all the time you can't tell them to lay
still because we're taking this
measurement so you have to sedate them
okay and if you take and sedate that
child for 2 minutes to get this full MRI
that might really hurt that sick child
that might be really unhealthy or have
bad health outcomes when you're sedating
sick infants for a long time so you can
collect this full image X ok so instead
if you could only sedate them you know
much less so that they only have to be
still for 30 seconds and you can collect
a quarter of the information and X but
you do it randomly you're willing to pay
that supercomputer price to solve for s
and invert to get the full image if it
means that you're you know maybe saving
infant's lives ok so it's very expensive
but sometimes it's worth it to measure a
dramatic subsample of the measurements
and infer what the nonzero coefficients
were other examples you just literally
can't measure the full resolution X and
so you try to design some randomized
measurements Y where you can infer the
nonzero Fourier coefficients
okay that was a lot of math we're gonna
talk more about this and I'm gonna help
you build more intuition for why this l1
norm is so useful in this compressed
sensing problem for promoting sparsity
all right thank you